It is time for hatred, mail. What is hatred?
Mail, quick reminder. Of course,
the right of the people to keep and bear hate
shall not be in phrase
the mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because freedom,
this week's hatred mail deals with a topic
that it's sort of a silly topic, but it is
more and more a part of, uh, the emails that
I'm getting from the audience. Take a listen
to this.
Americans are not so stupid as you, David.
They will never go socialist. Little less
talk. David Moore. Listen enough was stupid
milk. How can you take this Pacman dude? Seriously?
Is that even his real hair? I have no idea
why I'm still subscribed to this tripe.
Yeah, so despite it looking insane, this is
my real hair. People who watch the show have
been noticing that it's been months since
I've gotten a haircut. I just haven't had
time. I've had a lot of weekend travel combined
with all of the live streams, impeachment,
election, livestreams, state of the union,
a whole bunch of different stuff. So it could
be a very long time until I get myself a haircut.
The haircut plan is not going well, but it
is indeed my real hair. Don't worry. Uh, remember
that you can fight hatred. Autism by using
the coupon code hatred 40 when you sign up@joinpacman.com
use the code H. a T. R I. O. T for zero. You
save 40% and 40 hatred. It's cry every time
that coupon code is used.